hi today we're taking a look at
imagination augmented agents for deep
reinforcement learning this is a paper
by deep mud and has been in the news a
bit recently so we're going to have a
look at what it's all about
basically they claim that agents who
have a model of the world perform better
usually than agents who don't but of
course usually we don't have them all
over the world so they make the agent
learn the model of the world which you
can then use to plan now this learning
of the model can first be M imperfect
because it's learned and so they provide
a way to work with imperfect environment
models and combine them with model free
approach so what do we mean by models
and model 3 basically or you can say if
you have a model of the world and you
have kind of a machine pea box and in
this box you can you have a state s and
you feed the state to the Machine and
you feed an action and the model of the
world will tell you what did s Prime the
new States going to be and so this is in
the case where you exactly know how your
environment works now in a model free
approach what you would do is you would
you would plan basically you would have
a state and put that through some kind
of a layered neural network and out
would come what action should I take
right now so in the model-based approach
you're trying to try out all these
actions and tell you look which one
gives me kind of a desired final state
and then the model free approach you
simply used to
rewards to go directly saying here's my
state watch it my action be so this
paper is a combination of both the basic
architecture is here so let's start from
the from the very right if two paths
divided along this line the final policy
so which actions you're going to take
and what kind of values you can expect
it's going to be a result of two
different models that are combined
there's a model free path which means
this is what we talked about simply here
is this state and you gently feed it
through this neural network things
follow along out comes a policy or an
action you should take but then there's
also this other path and this is the
this imagination path basically consists
a bunch of these roll out encoders and
these roll out encoders is just the
agent imagining the future so the agent
doing some actions and looking at how
they will perform says this dumb there's
this some imagination core thingy but
this consists of is policy network and
an environment model so and this
environment model is really the core of
the entire thing so this environment
model you basically learn from what
you've seen so far so so far you've
taken certain actions here in certain
states you use this to to learn the
environment models that gives you from
one state the next state and the next
reward so that's that's what you learn
of course also using neural networks and
whatnot and you use that environment
model to imagine the future so here in
this imagination core basically you put
in your state you get out
some new state and some reward you feed
the new state and you imagine another
action of course the actions aren't
random the actions you also take real
this thing and this where it loops all
back this is an hour a model free policy
network that works with the environment
model so basically in your imagination
you only use if you look at the very
right here you only use this right path
and because your imagination doesn't
need to be like super exact or super
well-planned you can use the model free
approach that we kind of know kind of
works for some problems you use this to
generate your actions that you imagine
and you use an environment model in
order to look how these actions will
play out and that's how you imagine one
step of the future and you simply repeat
this a couple of steps and then you have
an entire what's called a rollout which
consists of these pairs of state and
rewards and what you do then is you can
code this roll out here this encoder
which is in this case an Alice chem or
something like this think you encode all
these states into one vector into one
embedding basically for this rollout and
this embedding describes kind of the
future imagined path of course what
you're going to hope is that some how
this encoding captures how you will do
in the future and how good this will be
so these states and rivers once you have
a couple of these robots that want to
imagine a couple different futures you
then aggregate them in this aggregator
think in their case they just
concatenate the these feeds roll out
encodings and then you feed this to to
the to the date
- the big aggregate on top so the big
aggregator on top can now combine the
model free pass and the imagined futures
so if the big aggregator things that the
imagination isn't correct it can reserve
to the model free pass but you can also
think that maybe it's correct or it can
be kind of a sixer it's correct you can
fully trust these roll outs and perform
actions according to that all this is of
course trained end to end there's a
there's a tiny piece we haven't looked
at yet namely how this here is quality
network on the Left we've learned and
and this is simply learned by and that
pay attention that I'm doing the right
thing here so you take this big thing
here your final policy network and you
you perform you kind of learn to copy
its actions simply from the input so
from this model free input over here you
take this input and you take this me and
you take the the output of your big
follow of your big policy network and
you try to simply make a neural network
that copies the output given these
inputs and that's kind of your small
policy network in here that simply model
free so on if the loop closes in a way
that you use your you use your your
learned model to then again imagine the
future but of course for imagining the
future within imagining the future you
can't have another instance of this
network because it would be infinite
recursion so you can only have a model
free network and all right that's it for
the model of course you gather a couple
of tricks and how to encode these things
basically they perform experiments and
this was maybe what you've seen in the
media so far of this game and this game
is a game where you have to push around
the brown boxes onto the red squares
using the green avatar that you have so
this game is difficult because first of
all the levels are generated randomly
and so there's no way you can like
hard-code anything and second of all if
you push box say this box here if you
were to push it to the right into the
corner you would have no way of getting
it out of the gap that's why I have to
plan ahead and avoid such mistakes
because yes they're not fixable so once
you make the mistakes you can't go back
and and that's where planning comes in
so handy if you imagine the future and
if your model is correct or
approximately correct then you can avoid
such mistakes of course that's yeah the
difficulty in this game and that's where
the planning helps note that they don't
they don't code in how the game works
so all these models get is pixel input
of the game and they have to kind of
imagine the pixel output they're going
to get so that's increased difficulty so
technically the the method is model 3 in
the sense that there's really no coded
model of the world just the pixels so
they have performance and a comparisons
in where if you and
I find this on the right here
interesting you can see according to the
unreal depth so how how much steps into
the future you imagine you can see it
kind of flattens out after only that
five steps whereas the game usually
lasts for about fifty steps they say so
only imagine five steps is already
really helpful what I don't like here is
that they compared to what they say this
copy model because this is here is in
standard model free comparison so it's
just a model free agent and of course it
perform of course but it performs worse
right here and it because it has no
imagination but it also has less
parameters so they're trying to compare
to something same amount of parameters
and say oh we have this copy model agent
here and what the copy model agency
students you need it simply it's um for
the environment model the same
architecture but for the environment
model it simply predicts the output as
the input so it's simply saying so you
do this action the environments going to
be exactly the same as it is now and I
don't like it because basically this
this entire branch here becomes rather
useless and so even though you have
parameters in here they're not useful so
to say that this is a comparison with
the model of the same amount of
parameters no technically true yeah
another thing that they do is they pre
train environment model from with the
model free agent so first they code a
model free agent and then they pre train
the environment model to then use with
this agent so it's not fully learned
intent I can imagine they tried and it
didn't
work and this is how you get it to work
so they they also experiment with
imperfect models and so they train the
environment model only imperfectly and
as you can see here this is kind of the
output you can get things duplicates you
have kind of errors this twice here
twice you your character here has like
boxes within the wall all kinds of
things and it basically show that if you
try to classically plan using these
models these bad models you get nowhere
discs see this is a Monte Carlo sampler
planner using a poor model and it
performance degrades significantly from
when you use the good model which is
right here and the imagination agent is
not affected by it kind of the bad model
except that it takes kind of longer to
reach it to reach its its height in
accuracy all right so there's a couple
of other experiments and pac-man
experiments where they show you can
learn one model to transfer kind of to
play different games in this pac-man
world and that just works the more if
you have very sparse rewards which you
imagine yes if you need to plan them
that's what you you get you get the
ability to earn more sparse rewards you
can rather look ahead alright so I think
I'll conclude here with the discussion
of this paper I quite liked it and the
cool method combines many things and I
see you next time